first my brain done
there's no need to exaggerate the
current cost of living crisis it's scary
enough as it is just ask any family
losing sleep over how to pay their bills
or stand into open mouth silence at the
supermarket checkout the cost of food
fuel and essential household products is
rocketing around the world prices are
rising by nine percent in the uk alone
the last time inflation was so high was
in 1982.
so this is the worst financial situation
we've faced in 40 years and a
desperately worrying time for millions
of people when there's economic meltdown
like this we expect those whose job it
is to fix it to offer us free things
solutions common sense and calm instead
the governor of the bank of england the
most important financier in britain is
running around like a hysterically
hyperbolic headless chicken
the one that
i am going to sound i guess rather
apocalyptic about is food
sorry for being apocalyptic for a moment
but that is a that's a major concern
have you felt a bit helpless through
this
period
well yes i mean it is very very i mean
more than uncomfortable i'm trying to
think of a word that's even more severe
than that
helpless helpless
andrew bailey you're you're the governor
of the bank of england it's literally
your job to help us
not be helpless
and if the apocalypse is truly upon us
that nothing you do or say matters
that governor is the apocalypse
literally the end of the world we'd all
be dead
now you might think that bailey and his
team are working around the clock in
their offices to rescue us but you would
be wrong we learned today that bailly is
allowing his staff to work from home
four days a week presumably they're all
sheltering their private home bunkers
from the impending armageddon bailly
also says everybody else should think
and reflect before asking for a pay rise
which is pretty rich coming from him
when his salary is 575 000 pounds a year
and when he's managing the economy with
all his staff setting a home on the sofa
in their briefs on zoom
meanwhile the former chief economist of
the bank of england says
maths should be rebranded because it's
frightening andy haldane told the times
it should be called numeracy which he
says is less scary
what is he talking about
perhaps he took his numeracy lessons
like this
we had three bats and one more sasha
makes one two
three four
all together four battlefield buttes i i
mean four beautiful bats
that was count dracula get it
terrifying huh but the last thing we
need in all seriousness right now is a
ridiculous debate about whether poor
little snowflakes can handle the word
mass without going into spontaneous
anaphylactic shock the only thing that's
really frightening about the numbers
right now and you haven't got to be
einstein to work this out is rocketing
inflation
the governor and his stay-at-home staff
should get serious about a serious
situation stop waving the white flag of
surrender stop using woefully
irresponsible language and get the hell
back to the
office the british monarchy undoubtedly
has a lot to answer for if you consider
the grand sweep of history king henry
viii had what's now known as a highly
problematic relationship with women
especially when they were in close
proximity to guillotine his daughter
queen mary was a big fan of burning
protestants in front of large crowds
which is all now frowned upon and don't
even get me started king george iii
without his madness and incompetence i
would almost certainly be addressing you
now as the king of the united states of
america
the truth is that britain's had kings
and queens for about 1200 years and as
with u.s presidents some have been dumb
mean malevolent or useless others
including the current queen have been
magnificent similarly the british empire
was responsible for very good things and
some very bad things but they all
happened in the past a long time ago
different rules different rulers a
different age that's how history tends
to work
none of it has got anything to do with
today's royal family but today sadly
every royal tour is now dominated by a
shrieking chorus of demands from social
justice stirrers for them to issue
endless apologies for the past
the lady's target's prince charles is
visiting canada to mark the queen's
platinum jubilee
we must find new ways
to come to terms with the darker and
more difficult aspects of the past
acknowledging
reconciling
and striving to do better
it is a process that starts with
listening
it is but once you start apologizing
your royal highness trust me on this
it'll never stop
the royals face demands rights groups in
canada to formally apologize for the way
indigenous people were treated during
the age of empire this after the
encounters of wessex faced protests over
britain's historic links to slavery on a
visit to the grenadines and the duke and
duchess of cambridge were met with
demands for reparations in jamaica now
look it's beyond question that the
british empire committed atrocities by
the enlightened standards of today's
world just as it is beyond question that
there are many things we can be ashamed
of in our past
but there are also many reasons why we
should be extremely proud to be british
we're a great country that's done many
great things
yet all of the good stuff is being
forgotten as the royals embark on what
now seems to be an endless groveling
apology tool for the behavior of
ancestors well i've got an apology and
it's this i'm sorry but i'm finding
these constant apologies by the royals
increasingly irksome
obesity's reached epidemic proportions
globally with at least 2.8 million
people dying because of it each year
more than half of young american adults
are either overweight or obese in
england and scotland obesity is now a
bigger cause of death than smoking but
rather tackle this problem head-on with
the action that's urgently required woke
warriors want health professionals to
ease off on the global fat fight because
you guessed it it's racist
the university of illinois chicago
school of public health says weight
stigma is discrimination or stereotyping
based on a person's weight and is one of
the last types of discrimination still
condoned and carried out by public
health and medical experts this report
says focus on body size is rooted in
racism dating back to charles darwin and
the stigmatizing words like obesity
should be dropped for terms like people
in larger bodies
for the love of god
the people being lectured about all this
are doctors highly educated medical
professionals they should be allowed to
get on with their jobs without worrying
about upsetting people who need to lose
weight and by the way here's a pro tip
if you do want to lose weight and take
it from me someone is carrying a bit of
excess timber the way to do it is to do
a bit more exercise and stick with
little less food and alcohol down your
gullet that normally tends to work the
idea is now deemed racist to criticize
morbid obesity is yet another symptom of
the woke virus is grip on common sense
we now know the higher mortality rates
from covert 19 in the black community
were linked to obesity when we tell the
medics who are mobilized in the fight on
fact to stand down because it's racist
we're actually putting our minority
communities at greater risk of poor
health and death and that ironically is
racism
professional footballers are among the
most lavishly paid athletes in the world
top players can earn millions every
month for kicking a ball around which
obviously sounds ridiculous in an
economic crisis but their salaries are
driven by market force they get paid a
lot of money because they're the best of
what they do and they make a lot of
money for their teams and the same
simple economic calculation should apply
to men and women that's why i'm in total
agreement today with the groundbreaking
decision by the u.s soccer federation
not with their decision to call
themselves soccer federation it's
football but their decision to pay its
women team the same amount it pays the
men u.s women have fought hard for equal
pay for years and here's their
victorious captain today
i am feeling extreme pride and to be
able to say finally equal pay for equal
work feels very very good
well she should she's earned it they all
have the us women's football team is a
ruthless winning machine skilled strong
resilient champions they've won four
world cups four olympic goals compare
that with the us men's team which has
won absolutely nothing it's about as
entertaining to watch as a meghan markle
podcast it's not realistic right now for
all female sports teams or individual
sports women to earn the same as male
counterparts it depends on the sport the
level of success their star power and
particularly on revenue streams from
crowds and television but in this case
it's a no-brainer the u.s women's team
may be very smug
and annoying
but honestly they've got every right to
be
they're more successful than the u.s
men's team by far they get bigger crowds
just as many sponsors and actually much
bigger stars
if anything they should be paid more
than the men
you